[Music]
one thing we are sure
about personal finance is that it is 80
behavior
it's only 20
head knowledge
so anything in your life that affects
your behavior positively or negatively
is actually more important
than the technical
financial
teaching
the technical finance understanding the
details of an investment important
controlling the person in your mirror
absolutely vital and so when you have
things happen to you
um
you need to give yourself a little bit
of a
somehow we feel like we have to be like
financial superman financial superwoman
even when
we're really going through a hard time
yeah like our last caller who just lost
her husband yeah
you know you don't have to be superwoman
well i think it's that i think also
sometimes like you said it might even be
um it can be a coping strategy where
we're like i just want to do stuff i
want to control what i can control but
to your point
there's not a
timeline you have to do all this on and
so one of the most powerful things you
can do and this is with money decisions
but any decision
is just consider the season that you're
in and i don't think we do that enough
dave whether it's with your your health
your family your work your business even
your money when you consider the season
that you're in then you can set goals
and make plans that are
a reflection of what's going on in that
season so the season of mourning after
losing your husband might not be the
time to knock at all your all your
checklists on your uh you know going
through all the paperwork stuff it might
be something you do more gradually over
six to nine months than in those first
um few months and so i think there's
just there's something really powerful
of stopping checking in with yourself
considering the season that you're in
before you put all the pressure on
yourself because sometimes we put
pressure on ourselves and it's not the
right time the right season for that
pressure or that goal well and i think
the reason we do is we we've lost this
we've got this disconnect
as if finance sits over here in its own
little column
of our life this own little silo of our
life and everything else is over on the
other side
and it's like but and so no matter
what's going over in our the big swath
of our life somehow we're supposed to be
okay with the money part yeah or we're
supposed to uh
you know uh not do uh you know not be
susceptible to stress spending or or
grief spending or not be of course you
are right and people do some of the
dumbest things
when their personal life is messed up
yeah with money yeah or when their
personal life is going like really
really good yeah and they feel
invincible like i got the midas touch
everything i touch turns to gold and
no you don't yeah yeah no you don't i
mean you know you get you get this high
because everything seems to be working
and then you go do something that's
super high risky but in your mind
because everything's been going good
it's nice it doesn't feel super high
risky yeah so of course it's super hot
risky well and i think the the bottom
line too is in any of these extremes
whether you're an extreme of of grief or
healing or even just you know you've got
a lot going on you're busy maybe you're
just super tired
it's hard to think clearly in those
times it's hard to think clearly when
you're mourning it's hard to think
clearly when you're exhausted and just
trying to keep your head above water and
so i think that when you can get into a
space where you can think clearly then
you're going to make better decisions
but if you're just reacting you're just
flying by the seat of your pants or
trying to just
control things to control them you're
not necessarily going to make the best
decisions you need to think clearly and
get out of that in order to make better
decisions
so
deloney talked about this and john dr
john delaney when we were going through
kobe this time last year and people were
in freak out mode that when you're when
your brain is in freakout mode whether
it's anger fear
pain grief
whatever you're just overwhelmed with
emotion
it shuts down your critical thinking
skills yeah
because you go into fight or flight yes
and uh he talked about that and and you
know we kind of all know that from a
common sense but hearing it from a phd
yes made it sound smarter but um
i'm not sure he is but anyway he sure
has a lot of sure has a lot of letters
after his name but um it makes sense
though but yeah so
hint
all of us
have periods of time in our life short
and long
that there is extreme emotion
do not
make big financial decisions
during a moment of extreme emotion yeah
the logic part of your brain is
literally not working a hundred percent
of your decisions suck
during that time because you are not i
mean you know i'll give you an example
when people get scared they get super
scared they get desperate
right after you get desperate is when
you fall for get rich quick
and you get conned
because you're like i'm 58 i just woke
up and realized i've got no money
i got to retire
and they all said they go into orbit
right yeah and and what they do they go
some of the dumb butt get rich quick
investing stuff and they get ripped off
and so they destroy what little
opportunity they had
to actually catch up yeah which you can
do at 58 you're not gonna die you're
gonna make it
a little baby
but you know that when you when i get
desperate
right after i get desperate i get really
stupid well yes desperate decisions are
always bad ones we talk about this even
through entre leadership with hiring
when you're desperate you're gonna make
a bad hire oh cause you're just
desperate you're not thinking clearly
it's it's it's true with anything though
we ken coleman and i have talked about
this when we've hosted the show on
fridays together we have people calling
in and they took a job that was the
wrong job because they were desperate
and i was like man that was a bad
decision what do you do then so
desperate that's such a good point
desperate decisions are are always bad
decisions i had a friend that married a
woman that he shouldn't america because
he was desperate that's that's that's
next level that's next level
oh it costs you a lot of money though
i'm just saying
headaches and stress and
it goes bad and the same thing could be
true some lady that hired or married a
bad dude i mean
both ways yep it's expensive mistake
yeah serious so all kidding aside
with all the stuff happening with covid
[Music]
with
grief
around any kind of a situation
you get fired
well what happens you go through the
stages of grief yeah you get mad you're
in denial
you blame other people it's probably
your fault but you don't come to that
immediately
might not be your fault i don't know i
got fired one time and the guy
i never knew why i got you still don't
know why no and he died so i'll never
find out and he cussed me out when he
fired me so i really i mean you know i
should be nice about it but he's dead
and so but yeah so i one of the things i
vowed around here over all these years
is if we're gonna let someone leave
they're gonna at least know why and
they're gonna if if at all possible had
a lot of warnings yes yeah a lot of
heads up about it but if you get fired
and get caught off guard that lady in
our earlier segment been with tyson 30
years yeah didn't work out yeah oh you
heard oh yeah you hear the pain yes
there's a story there at the new plant
there's a story there yeah and if while
that stuff is in your stomach and coming
up into the back of your throat
not a good time to buy a house yeah yeah
yeah yeah not a good time to you know
suddenly say i'm going to open a
business and go 400 000 in debt yeah to
medicate the fact that i'm really
hurting pissed off and wondering about
my own
worth in the world and personal finance
so the more stable
steady
consistent
predictable the person yeah the higher
probability they build wealth you know
i'm curious your thoughts on this when
you said that you made this reference to
starting a business uh ken coleman and i
when we were hosting the show a couple
weeks ago we got the blinds.com question
it was this woman who had a salon for 22
years
closed it due to covid and then was not
sure what to do now and in her you know
when they submit these questions we
don't can ask follow-up but open
reopening salaam wasn't an option and it
led me to wonder i wonder how many
businesses
closed in covid because of you know
whatever the the expenses and all that
but then didn't reopen not because the
business wasn't viable again
but because they were so hurt they're
broken they felt so
like they failed like they were because
i'm going to just breathe
ramsay investments
and i had this cool sign and i had to
take it off the wall
it did something it was
it was not just closing a business i
turned the key that's right in that door
the last time and walked away from that
building
it was like the death of a dream
and uh it was a very real thing did i
need to be making major life decisions
of any kind money included during that
time no right
so you know you just gotta at any point
of high emotion positive or negative
take a chill pill
wait a beat
or three before you make major financial
decisions